we have a voicemail number that number
is 219
to david p uh here's something we heard
from troy york you know i'm hearing this
from a lot of people which is basically
now that trump is gone
your show is dead david it's dead
you know just uh i bet secretly you had
to be rooting for president trump
because
i think that you as a podcaster uh you
are done
right i mean if you don't have trump
around what the hell is the david pagman
show going to talk about
and you're not even get your
international funding anymore there's
there's no point in
right funding which i don't have
programs like you
david pakman and sam cedar you guys are
done
right so i don't know why you celebrate
and we're
pushing so hard against trump when in
fact you're not gonna have no content
right you know what's fascinating about
this is that when obama
won and defeated george w bush i got all
the same emails
you're now on the inside and it's not
going to be there's not going to be
nothing to do
the show quadrupled during obama raised
venture capital i mean it was
it was like crazy the obama era was
completely crazy for us but i got
worried
troy maybe troy's on to something here
maybe we're done
so i went and looked and in the short
five day period since the inauguration
we had live stream views in the millions
we continued to have one or even two
million views a day on the youtube
channel even through the weekend when we
normally see a dip
we added 11 000 new youtube subscribers
uh and one of the biggest growth weeks
we've ever had on our instagram igtv
channel
was uh the last week during and since
the inauguration
and you know the the reality is there
are always things going on
right wing media is going to be nuts the
next two years
these trumpian right-wing elected
officials are going to be nuts and some
of our best performing clips of the last
three months and during the last three
months trump did a lot of crazy things
even during the last three months and
in the have been since the time of
trump's departure
our coverage of lauren bobert and these
other insurrectionists
the focus group with republican voters
one of our top clips sean hannity
claiming biden's doing
re-education camps this has been a thing
forever you're circling the drain now
that the winds are changing politically
and then we grow and we grow and we grow
and if the last five days are any
indication
the next three months could be really
crazy but you know i'm really glad that
through the years troy has stuck with us
he seems to love the show because he
knows everything that's going on here
we will talk to you more on today's
bonus show
get instant access by becoming a member
at joinedpakman.com we will talk about
the death of larry king
we will talk about the candidacy of
sarah huckabee sanders
for governor of arkansas and much much
more
sign up and get instant access at
joinpakman.com